wir machen das jetzt aber eben mit einer
hexe wenn ich da jetzt mal seinen kopf
bekommen würde wenn in exeter auch cool
mal direkt im kopf bekommen hätte sind
wunderschöne hexen kopf die ich der deg
knuffig hallo ich meine lieben ville de
paris und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen mod vorstellungen zwar von der
elastic beck bot und zwar es tut mir
erst mal wenn mein bauch hier nebenbei
ein bisschen grummeln ich hab grad total
hunger aber ich wollte dieses video
jetzt noch zu einigermaßen vertretbaren
uhrzeit hier hochladen
es ist eine modifikation für die
minecraft 1.7.2010 fortschritt von 752
den installer herunterladen dann habt
ihr eine neue bordsteine der einzige
bleibt ist ja relativ easy alles links
in der beschreibung blabla also erstmal
das typische gelaber vorher
es ist eine modifikation die einerseits
eine spaß modifikation ist also die
quasi schwachsinn zurück aber
andererseits auch sehr coole sachen und
zwar ziemlich wieder nicht wenn man das
kates luca sondern wenn man drücken
synlab ins inventar geht dann habe ich
mir hier schon einen diamant schwert
geholt einfach nur um gleich die mobs zu
töten
ich habe jetzt hier auch schon mal
kik hole ich mir beispielsweise dann
hole ich mir mal eine kuh und was können
wir da noch holen
ich könnte mir nochmal button ihm bei
denn wir können ja war theoretischen
hexen ebene so jetzt können wir wieder
der seite weiterblättern ansehen wir
hier realistisch also aus ihrer
realistik detmold und annehme hier die
ganzen dinge die hinzugefügt werden ich
möchte euch die hauptfunktion der
modifikation zeigen es gibt noch updates
von dieser mod ihr findet wie gesagt
alles an beschreiben der wirtschaft bei
diesen die komische riga fettsack so wie
ich mir ja ich würde einfach sagen ich
zeig euch mal das gröbste von diese
sachen weil der rest relativ unnötig
jetzt wie beispielsweise salt bottle ist
auch relativ egal jedenfalls ist einzige
was ich erst mal zeigen möchte ich spawn
jetzt erstmal ein paar schweine und zwar
funktioniert es nicht bei jedem schein
sondern nur bei einigen so hier hat sich
zum beispiel gerade nicht funktioniert
dann immer diese scheinen da hat sie
mich hat auch nicht funktioniert in der
nehmen mal das schwein jetzt auch nie
funktioniert wir müssen nicht was ein
bisschen abfahrt und zwar funktioniert
es wirklich nicht bei jedem ob das ganze
hier hat jetzt beispielsweise
funktioniert jetzt haben wir hier
nämlich ein mob getötet und jetzt haben
wir auch was ich keine volkmann und
jetzt haben wir hier so einen
schweinekopf und jetzt legt euch erstmal
was kann ich denn damit machen
wenn jemand jetzt erst mal einen kaffee
microchip form holzschiff von kulig kann
das schiff gedrückt halten sie gar nicht
used to get more troops for peace also
dass sie beschreiben wir sogar nur
rechts klicken möchte ich auch noch mal
ganz kurz eigentlich in den games 0 g
und versuche das ding abzubauen
kann ich jetzt zehn jahre sitzen jetzt
funktioniert nicht geht es auf einmal
das vorhin mit dem kopf gemacht da ging
das nicht aber gut hab ich also mit dem
kopf gerade ging es gar nicht ich konnte
gar nicht kaputt machen gerade
war komisch ist gerade aber okay wir
nehmen das jetzt einfach mal noch mal
die ebenso ein schwein und zwar aber das
ist aber auch cool dass letztjährigen
kopf bekommen haben
weise entscheidend das kann daran liegen
dass das vorhin versucht habe so
abzubauen ich meine creative not stimmt
ach ich vollidiot ja gut da kann man es
auf jeden fall doch abbauen
wir können sich das kabinett darauf
machen und ihr seht schon was wir jetzt
alles im inventar haben wir haben elf
roboter wir haben einen rock brain wir
haben zwei rostock wir haben ein rohr
hart also ein frohes herz 1 3 hohen
lumen zwei teams bin ich mir gar nicht
sicher sind dass nieren ich weiß es kann
gar nicht drei knochen und drei päckchen
traurig das wissen nur 3 pkt
weil man damit auch noch coole sachen
machen kann aber das sage ich euch
gleich und zwar erst mal viele denken
sich jetzt sowieso kriegt man da so
viele sachen von einem schwein hat auch
beispielsweise niemals drei lungen oder
irgendwie zwei brüche oder irgendwie
sowas oder die hier natürlich an
schweinen oder elf von diesem fleisch
scheint sogar 14 stück abwärts insgesamt
natürlich nicht aber das sind
random drops also das wird komplett
random entschieden wie viel ihr habt es
kann auch sein dass sie einfach mal
anstatt sagen als fünf euro pop shop
könnt ihr auch mit teilweise nur eins
bekommen oder teilweise sieben oder
teilweise vier lungen oder teilweise
dann halt nur eine lunge das ist halt
relativ random ich kann natürlich auch
noch mal zeigen wenn ich jetzt noch mal
so ein schwein töte beziehungsweise
solange bis ich wieder so ein kopf
bekommen dass das ganze rennen ist super
hier jetzt koffer ein kopf-an-kopf nähe
war kein kopf und ich möchte ich noch
eben sondern jetzt habe ich die kleine
scheint indes pont nein nein ich möchte
nicht die kleinen männchen klicken
okay wir lassen das glaube ich mal weil
das ist halt echt rennen drops und
random auch ob irgendwann kopf dabei und
wird also ich würde sagen bevor wir das
jetzt zehn jahre lang weiter machen wir
weiter im programm und zwar was ich euch
zeigen wollte ist dass man mich jetzt
eben hier so einen ofen holen kann dann
in dem ich jetzt mal einfach den ofen
stellte mir hin
stell dir vielleicht mal so ein paar
mehr höfen hin so und hole mir jetzt ein
paar bringt mit tirols wie
beispielsweise kohle platziere hier
jetzt mal die kohle und die lungen reine
beispielsweise die kohle und die kit
nichts hier beispielsweise mal kohle und
pick haitis das cool finde ich denn
jetzt zum beispiel mal ein gehirn und
kohle
dann können wir hier auch beispielsweise
mal in den bauch einpacken dann bräuchte
ich eventuell sogar noch mehr höfen mal
ganz kurz weil das ganze doch nicht wahr
ich ziehe ich gerade dann kann ich immer
das herz reinpacken und das noch beraten
dann gar nicht mehr noch die parkstadt
reinpacken
die hauptstadt media ist natürlich die
pop reinpacken und braten wo ihr seht
schon es wird jetzt alles gebraten hier
bekommen wir diese gekochten lungen
angebratenen gelungen
hier bekommen die kippen ist ja nur eine
andere farbe dann haben wir kick es ist
ein bisschen intensiver von der farbe
des brain sieht komplett anders aus das
nicht mehr so eklig bauen
der comic ist auch ein bisschen
intensiver von der farbe dann können wir
das herz ist auch ein bisschen brauner
geworden und hier disco pop shop käme
wahrscheinlich und das tolle ist wir
können alles hier von essen ich kann es
euch jetzt nicht zeigen weil ich im
creative bin und auch ein gamer wäre das
relativ doof weil ich das ganze hier
da müsste ich wieder so lange rum laufen
bis überhaupt mal hungrig bin das kann
ich aber eben machen nebenbei ja auch so
ein bisschen schlagen dann werde ich
eventuell irgendwann mal hungrig und
dann kann ich euch das mal zeigen dass
man nämlich die ganze kacke hier
aufessen kann sollte man hier die welt
kaputt blabla dann zeige ich euch
wenigstens dass man hier so als könne
sich zum beispiel mal was kein essen
ich esse jetzt einen schweine magen so
die jetzt bin ich total hungrig nicht
mehr hungrig weil ich jetzt in schweine
mal gegessen aber so das ist richtig
richtig krank was man hier alles
mitmachen kann mit diesen ganzen sachen
und das alles nur mit diesem kabinett
die kräfte findet auf der website ich ob
das muss jetzt nicht alles zeigen
allerdings wollte ich auch noch zeigen
dass das ganze natürlich mit
verschiedenem okay ich habe speziell
seine kuh da können jetzt auch wieder
mal von sondern auch jetzt hatte ich ihr
nur eins bauen lässt ja ich bin ja im in
game zu null ist natürlich klar
ich nehme mal ganz kurz hier noch mal so
eine kur aus spore niemals ein paar töne
die man alle kann natürlich nur hoffen
dass ich hier wieder irgendwie sonst um
kopf mal bekomme nein warum neueste den
weg bliebe kuh
also ich kann das auch mit dieser masche
machen weil ab und genau der gleiche
coup raus sind desto wird halt wenn man
das ganze zeigen will das ist halt nur
eine bestimmte chanson russell zu nennen
nicht aufgeholt werden keine kuh damals
beispielsweise kopf hier bekommen
ich mag man das gras weg damit wir
können jetzt is coming out nehmen
einfach mal rächt sich drauf machen und
jetzt seht ihr was wir alles im inventar
an damit diese in diesem kopf einfach
nur bekommen wer im creative sind und
während sie beispielsweise noch ein
remis haben ein rostock wieder drei
jahre lang sieht man zum beispiel zwei
nieren als es das gleiche wie quasi
dieses dieses pack haid und zwar kann
man sich damit diese richtung machen wir
sehen die pps und zwar kann man sich
damit diese diese rüstung machen quasi
und ihr seht schon wenn ich jetzt mal
anziehe beispielsweise also man muss die
diese sache dann quasi diese dieses
pickup magath gesehen habe ich einfach
im ofen getan habe ich gebratener
dichtheit und das könnte dann einfach so
anordnete inventar wie beispielsweise
wenn ihr euch eine reise rüstung macht
und ihr seht jetzt schon mal wenn ich
die mal ans hier wie für rüstung die
überhaupt macht die macht richtig viel
rüstung die macht glaube ich sogar mehr
als ein eisen rüstung
also das ist der relativ krank was die
alles für für eigenschaften hat dies
richtig richtig gut und ist quasi nur
ein paar schweine töten
obwohl eigentlich auch nicht schwer zu
kriegen wir machen das jetzt noch eben
mit einer hexe wenn ich das mal so einen
kopf bekommen würde wenn die nächste
töte ach guck mal direkten kopf bekommen
die wunderschöne hexen kopf
die klubs können von einer hexe alles
bekommen da bekommen wie zum beispiel
eine glasplatte
von klaus manhart gewimmelt also auf
jeden fall so ein paar sachen die der
pixel fertigungs geschrieben ein paar
sachen die kann sie so typisch für so
eine hexe sind also sozusagen womit man
halt brown kann klosters und glas
bottles also ein paar coole sachen es
wäre auch ganz geil wenn wenn wille
jamals leben finde ich ganz cool
aber das wird eventuell noch alles
hinzugefügt wenn euch die mod weitere
interessiert könnt ihr in der
beschreibung gucken und dann auch andere
dinge heraus wie beispielsweise wie das
mit dem welthit mit mit den fledermaus
schon dass es jetzt vielleicht müssen
justin halt's maul
wenn man so ein paar sachen hier so
weisen nicht so machen möchte also
irgendwie mit mit einer fledermaus geht
das bild ebenfalls würde ich sagen wenn
es euch gefallen hat dann würde ich mich
definitiv über eine bewertung freuen
und jetzt bitte meine stimme schon
wieder krank ich denke ich werde auch
macht krank aber wenns euch weiterhin
interessiert
er schreibt mir die ganze zeit an ich
glaube das ist ein zeichen das video zu
beenden
ich möchte mir lange drumherum bleiben
mir spaß macht diesem ort vorzustellen
weil sie relativ viele coole sachen
hinzufügt und endlich mal quasi so ein
bisschen mehr macht als wenn man scheint
würde dass man nur fleisch bekommt finde
ich sehr sehr cool und dann würde ich
sagen dass man in paris